well there's a guy up there right I hit
him
help me I'll see you now you're enjoying
the not really I mean it's I'm hitting
him dude I hit him twice
oh so low rate Han Solo yeah getting
burnt out already on Star Wars I have
yet this Jar Jar they should make a spin
a while I support it I'd see it yeah
he's gonna have me like it'd just be
like Jar Jar big Jar Jar just a badass
[ __ ] goon just he just clumsily
before they find out he's an elite
soldier oh damn it back out of this
you're my bro alright don't say see
mcgriffin said yeah record yeah we're
record all right we're all good man hey
let's go to the farm okay now my audios
being included hey everybody
where's your show where's the Comedy
Store oh nice was in like the belly room
drop it
oh the or see a dress oh geez
I'm sorry got away from you to the farm
but nobody who's everybody Hawking here
we go you know he has a
passive-aggressive way of doing it to a
court in Portland yeah do you want to
play my first I need to make a t-shirt
saying you're gonna go like backpack
over here battlefront and I'll cook say
he's gonna come on place to Battlefront
that's called
hair car where's that card on yeah there
is yeah
our wait is that Frank is that Frank
like right that's your car oh yeah well
thanks like 718 long did I haven't had
any not yet let's go yeah I know now
record on my thing on the last time oh
there's a guy up there right
I hit him help me I'll see you now
you're enjoying the I'm hitting him dude
hit him twice
okay Battlefront just has great graphics
good sound I love how it looks
no yeah no battle fun it's nice looking
game Sony said they stay on
Jeremih wonders I heard y'all Jeremiah
wonders yeah I love Jeremy wait who's
what see whose feet are you well that's
on my feet that's also this oh well say
to your mom for me she's not interested
like a the audience hey I paid people
thankful spoons coming to us I've got
two shotguns and I've never been ready
yeah you didn't say anything either
so we're just the worst no matter what
exactly man is there anything over there
Phoenix it's just our guy our guy have a
house coming over I'm over here right
now I'm not there yet how my shakers so
[ __ ] annoying I'll be out of range
oh my god I got bandaged from except for
you especially wins the special [ __ ]
backpack man oh man this game do it
there was a tag on my backpack
okay yeah I just had a tunnel in the
other place what's on the ground there
I'll take that there's always that
friend okay oh you guys are guys we're
in the zone right now should we get in
this car oh yeah we're gonna go to
mansion well that sounds I guess the
master people well I get this guy in
Strand Oh Pete says fix your mud pitcher
Mike Craig Jesus what's wrong with it
picture I thought you had a headache why
are you even watching twitch that's not
good can you hear me
should be fine I don't know you guys can
hear me but yeah but it's like it's so
like argh I got down I'm actually gonna
buy a podcast mixer which actually will
work for this to USB right into my
[ __ ] uh yeah I'm telling you I'm gonna
get the whole list my guys coming in
tomorrow and we are we literally send
out emails with calls to a couple
companies about it I just haven't talked
about it we don't have the answers oh
great all right let me go let's let's
not all go in the same direction here I
mean love gathering points and you pick
up when you get to be like Darth Vader
sound like you is pulling them yesterday
just makes you more mad even peek even
Pikachu [ __ ] on you via [ __ ]
typing keyboard over here so that he
could take a break he has a headache
can't play with anyone
hey we play with dirty before he's a
good teeth right and dirty
what's up you said I'd be on ones you're
special to me on I don't know probably
June okay cool alright ready up what's
up dirty I'll be right there
I mean I knew Frank [ __ ] Boba Fett
man
Boba Fett's a beast yeah Z good night
baby
I could play with you but yeah Boba
Fett's the best we have a ranked up one
oh my god he's got rockets
you can like fly with them nice like it
makes it the only thing about this gave
you that's so [ __ ] annoying is you
have to rank up your your heroes if you
don't wake up the heroes they're wack
you know they're just yeah that makes
sense
did you watch the oh you were at the
Clippers game you know watch the awards
won best picture shape of water Jordan
Peele what the screenplay though shape a
lot what shape of water one you mean the
one yeah oh you know what's really crazy
is Natalie Portman once said that [ __ ]
after Golden Globes her next big movie
that's out is the [ __ ] movie written
and directed by white guy I don't even
know I don't even know what she said I
had to go to glow she's like it's all
men all female directors you know all
right guys I gotta bounce
I'll be back just follow me Oh
decked it oh you already did didn't you
I hate the ruins all right we'll do it
ever
I'm just gonna go to this little place
our chests
where's font dirty history's good at
this game oh that's probably a good idea
cuz you're the worst
Oh Holly tox match to know if he could
back it up Oh daily daily no Carson Daly
it's not loading in come on hoses let's
load in every we're gonna meet Craig up
would you do it
looking fast or slow and painful slow
and painful he would ever see that's
what you should have said chomp oh I'm a
chop
Oh I said you don't have to bros back I
got your back all right
I got no got a first-aid kit
you got bandages I have a gun so do I so
do I see what we got here and I got a
pistol combat pants thing is with
so hard to see where stuff is have you
won any games you have a nice dog a b1
okay sixteen
aha [ __ ] I need these painkillers in
real life
see that wasn't funny
that's again just [ __ ] not funny all
the way you said it
I need these painkillers oh it's over
here okay mini shirt this all right
[ __ ] seven adding a backpack to you
I'm gonna helmet there's painkillers
over here I can't pick them up though
I'm coming towards you
what is the zone or perfect actually
oh [ __ ] I changed all my stuff that's
Jenny's what how'd you do that I don't
know my settings are messed up site
settings and now somehow I just put the
language umgawa there's a bike helmet I
guess
[ __ ] oh yeah I guess if we go this way
alright now we gotta go to Watertown
summit ours yes
now when they've been here in Watertown
all right where is it
isn't anything in the church did you
guys just get to church fall need dirty
looks good on this point for the
residents
okay and then we'll read run to Frank
all right
a lot of running in this game yeah I
have nots the only thing I'm not a fan
of but
all you take is get here pika - I bet
Craig's in the first die yep
I'll better shot him the Lord on that
take a body shot off of the Lord once
again not funny won't stand through this
milord you see - Adam oh that's true
banana nobody will
and I usually die because coke sits
there and goes - all right I'm gonna
cheetah from ten miles away
no no I just know that you dice game
tribe will know there's an army of for
people just like [ __ ] destiny and
he'll run straight Adam I didn't run
that last time in fact I was a guy
knowing that there was sort of that
thankful you know I want I want this gun
which one that I have here this one or
this one
what's better is a SKS or the mini pro
team assume any fourteens like a DMR all
right you know I'm just gonna keep these
I got a shotgun over here this time cool
they're gonna get the [ __ ] business
there's a couple shotguns up here and
the Jews you take the sniper rifle I
already had it I just why cuz you know
I'd get kills with it yeah all right
here take it
dick back I'm gonna tear shotgun oh I
dropped that eight times for you
yes that's okay sir I want this
yeah I'll take that question
I want it let me pick up the [ __ ]
scope there I just put it on the gun
you're good
I was just back pack that's what I need
I need I need him off for this where's
that I see you guy sir well I don't have
any yeah I don't have any ammo it's
going Craig do you have him is that the
second - 125 125 he's over there
okay his buddies in the story which two
story no I got asked I could I could
[ __ ] hit this guy if I had ammo for
this guy
no they're by me guys here I'm dropping
this that should be your ammo
all right let me see if I can get eyes
on this guy I think they're going
further away I left the vehicle you know
oh I certainly can't buy the vehicle
they went around this house I got an
idea idea
oh [ __ ]
I counted three of them oh great
I'm behind you guys go check the showers
all right nobody at top
I'll see anybody around it but I can't
see on the other side of it looks clear
from this standpoint though how much
ammo you have for that good thing he's
got 30 because that's what I dropped I
got 16 I got 16 oh yeah no I got yeah
there's a I'm 30 I'll take it if you
don't want it I need five five six kind
of want to go up into that Tower this
tower secare sorry you think they're
still in the building
yeah that building with the definite
like scouting stuff said don't know that
one and that terrifies me terrified I'm
terrified let's hang it back by their
car give me a sec see if I can see
I heard complains it's playing
another artist he's coming behind sort
of past us
just past us yeah it's not two cars
there's two cars over there I see yeah I
see a guy hold on let's just chill yep
take the shots when you get it when you
can yeah yep
yeah where's yet is it west there's a
guy at 295 it's a building pretty far
away though I think you may move along
that tree line over there well they're
eventually gonna be coming back all
right there's a guy on the roof
he's at 285 yeah I'm moving back up on
the red zone I think I think I'm the
only guy that can really see him he's
moving now just on the edge of the red
zone mm-hmm
I see one yeah yeah Samus taking off
well yeah he's definitely same about 285
there they're in a building back there
it's further away here's what the follow
oh oh he's not - now he's in the water
he's coming on you soon
I say you could probably all right he's
out he's out now
come get him up okay yeah light him
that's me right there that's him
you hit him trying to find me
yeah hiding in the water
well there's one swim
he's down nice yeah I had another one
coming same way I got him down too funny
the other guys look to your left in the
water at least in one way I think it's
me see no he's like underneath water
I feel like there's definitely keep an
eye on the fish there's a lot of ammo
down here for you coke and this is it
that sniper ammo yeah I'm coming for it
oh [ __ ]
work out rabbit i [ __ ] fell I'm fine
I'm 16
oh it's an involute oh yeah Miami wasn't
5-7 6-2 7-6 to the next day oh that's
right so m4 here
someone should definitely snack I'm okay
whatever banana these two that I don't
know that last one
bandaged up real quick here comes blue
Oh far do we get it sure you gotta join
in to start moving someone to cover this
buggy with me we're getting a second
vehicle
what the [ __ ] should we just start
moving yeah he'll go well you want card
messes just stay here yep just hang out
should we come down here cook and see if
there's anything Craig let's let's go
this way
all right see that vehicle no we're
gonna have to go on the blue for a
second nice eagle vision grandma wonder
what that third guy went oh [ __ ]
he hightailed it out dude it wasn't he
didn't have a chance
Mack that seats three so let's go hope
let's go now we're gonna turn to oh [ __ ]
I would have jumped in the sidecar zone
[ __ ] yeah
orange is good oh yeah thank you
I mean that's gonna be tough but we
should go ten teams of four still watch
this little blue
make sure they're all teams might be
some TVs and [ __ ] I'll throw a left
careful beautiful know what is shooting
these things
somebody should
now she does it's that's good yeah those
are fights we there's not one again
that's about right
what stop will be playing yes
let's stop right below thank you lady
right here stop right below here
see look at that Craig we got somebody
saying now watching me pick up yeah yeah
yeah and the 15 min so yeah that should
sit for a minute sure mom
I hear ya doing
lifting things I'm taking this
I hate pushing from [ __ ] so I can push
it [ __ ] whatever you guys know where we
don't stuff that's first half square it
the way it's been at no it doesn't like
it's been looted I don't but the ones
behind her doors it there's a guy here
150 on the back house guy
make sure 157 safety oh yeah he's not
any he's on the outside nice in this
next house vehicles I got a guy where's
that one crawl I don't know careful
careful when you look at the bodies okay
[Music]
it wasn't in status cars everybody wants
it everywhere everybody to come this way
go first
we're still solid we're gonna ask a sto
[ __ ] there's seven six it's gonna come
it's gonna go down to this little town
yeah let's get in here go back here
seven six
I'm gonna go Vince nine five five six
I'm gonna take this Ridgeline
I gotta get those or 195 I got you guys
watching him back cool thank you
great careful rage okay that's just 185
okay the shots were close close to our
time
keep careful on our six but not the
houses yeah someone's gotta watch it
back to the house um I'm watching toward
the houses I think there's a lot of guys
at the tower there's also gonna be guys
on that [ __ ] watch that bridge
there's a car over there station annum
cocaine just watch them I'm shooting at
the car you shooting at them there's a
couple more back there we can just kind
of wait for these guys
gonna have to come yeah why did honestly
they're gonna have to cross the bridge
yeah and we can let them up they're not
gonna see they're not gonna see where
I'm at I'll tell you that
oh are you got a guy I got guys coming
down the hill right here yep nice I'm
gonna run
a general super wedding there's nothing
bad
yeah motorcycle hunting what
flit through I got Instagram guy someone
oh yes only she didn't my eloquence to
go to your right foot Phoenix yeah I got
a heel yep he's trying to snipe me
alright
oh he's to the left of us they're coming
from the north
don't give them left
well no this five bottl oh there's the
for others for that you know guys we
have the best spot so we get chill here
just cover an extra price night out here
I'm in Norwich Powell said I'm out of
ammo
the sniper gun I got I need that seven
sticks to everything careful they're
trying to snipe incoming Phoenix I'm
dropping somewhere here okay alright yep
perfect they did I need a bandage some
more
there we go careful coming up there
coming up I see him where is the hit one
they're going through the 5000 yep
fellas I know there's too many things
range that was luck they might have a
sniper in there in the rock Kathryn aid
I think it came a little from the other
side I took it might be split in two in
two I think it's different teams yeah
there's people there's people in the
houses too oh [ __ ] oh sure there's only
two alive now I just be careful just
coming in now I think there are the
people at the ridge line
yeah that's you alive at a great
sacrifice laughs people gold sacrifice
yourself know they'll have to push goes
right yeah the circle we got okay we got
the circuit watch our issue a house
there and moves yeah
what's that the pave Hawks do you know
and then the pausing the rocks the rocks
at 100 the rocks yeah they're on the
right side but the I see him I seem all
right there's one that's trying to pose
yep left left
there's one of the tree right there they
strike all right where's the shooter
he's shooting me on this other side of
the building he's on he's in the back of
that first rock that they ran to he got
me he knocked me down what the [ __ ] I'm
coming I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming
cover us
you guys hold it down stay here in the
[ __ ] I can't I can't
we're gonna die I'm afraid dude we're
gonna kill it's gonna come on guys I got
one down push I got one down one left
looks fired push hard push hard push
hard I was close yeah blue comes in at
that point
at that point he can't you can't do it
anything no you just say he had to just
squeeze he just had to walk into the
circle but he would have would have been
dead before you brought him up yeah I
need a cigarette break hey I'm not
taking a side lead you played like a
[ __ ] that's what happens this is the
funny thing Frank always whenever we're
playing destiny 2 and we're getting our
ass whooped by a team before Fred he's
the guy that goes we need to stick
together they're sticking together and
you
watch him go by himself into an army of
for DES whenever there's something on
the line between us I think everybody's
like mysterious at first
little [ __ ] he plays like the scared us
a little bit you do I don't think you
hit anybody with your gun I'm pretty
sure you did a [ __ ] person I did that
whole [ __ ] time I swear to God and
you didn't you I hit the guy on the bike
I hit the down the bum you didn't hit
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah I'll take yourself
down [ __ ] okay like a [ __ ]
just know that you play like a [ __ ] I
play thanks sir all I'm saying is I
didn't doctors that's all set yeah and
your [ __ ] your but [ __ ] dirty
over there [ __ ] hide it in forever I
didn't beat up anybody he wasn't he was
be f ed I was the first one to get shot
I saw her there coming from I hid out a
bandaged oh did the gun I gave you I was
trying to kill one of the gangsters on
the other team the last two I was trying
to kill one of them you didn't do [ __ ]
you waited back and let dirty do all the
work know what he did all the work for
everybody that right there is the truth
dirty did did yeah he did a lot of it
but I tried you didn't even try you just
[ __ ] we're crouching over there I'm
doing anything oh god Pikachu shut the F
up why are you not on Pikachu it was
[ __ ] about playing I'm ready when you
guys are we're waiting on dirty more way
not dirty no you're good
[Music]
thank you
I wish out of scope though that was my
thing I didn't have anything with that
it was hard to see what the guns I had
it's nice when you get a scope how was
that my lord I haven't done it yet I'll
do it after this game this [ __ ] [ __ ]
got Craig gotta hate Craig sometimes
these are there but you know your
pleasure being all quiet that the when
Craig's playing hard it means he's not
even playing the game it means he's
playing like he thinks he should he
should he plays like he says everybody
should play when we're getting [ __ ] up
he's like everybody needs to stick
together and then he just [ __ ] runs
out half the time and dies you're going
I don't know what's up with you right
now
alright you know you know the deal let's
go let's go to the school what do you
guys say schools so crazy let's go yeah
it'll be fun no well knock them out and
if you want fun let's go for chengqi
hard horse patinka right we drop it go
go pinky what am I going to read I'll
show you when I green or going red for
houses right here
all right I'm right yep time oh yeah
there's a [ __ ] right yeah
there's a bunch of [ __ ] okay
here we go
oh I got an idea a meeting cook will
give oh you went to those let's go to
the interestin no no no no I'm by it I'm
just going to these outskirt houses
things I'll have anything ribs they
might watch me let me do the best golden
watch sorry
Turkey's actually right next to you
Thursday there he's the best yes too
good escape eating some action
[ __ ] too you know oh yeah I got us I got
a [ __ ] sickle like I know nothing
this is fun oh here we go BAM when you
get guns ready up on me I got guns bro
oh [ __ ] me I got a blank take top two
let's [ __ ] go oh I'm coming let's
[ __ ] let's Merc some [ __ ] so
I don't want to be guns I got guns i got
nothing i got grenades this is gonna be
great there's nothing in this [ __ ]
house dude what is this garbage there's
the first aid kit no I don't want that
that's for somebody I'm fun guys
oh [ __ ] is he on you
is that us what that's yeah
oh no they're downstairs I actually
might have been you you know right up in
me I know you're right there
let's push for a dirty one I'm comin
again all I gots a [ __ ] shotgun [ __ ]
sucks anybody have any extra sides
nope nope I'm looking now I'll speak the
devil I just got a holographic I'm
getting stuff I need it there's a kind
of Street 200 we're in the morning he
just dropped out nosey easiest to go
behind you behind you yep
nice careful treads all guys they're
gonna employ we'll be all right
I'm outside yeah yeah the best on me you
have anything good buddy I see just
coming to your house
he's comin near Frank's coming in I got
him down here comes his boy there's a
guy in Phoenix in gold chest there's a
gallon where the last two I saw a guy go
right I saw like guilty not in our house
oh I'm getting shot show
he's probably was outside he's outside
he's in the window
yeah I'm coming upstairs there's another
guy in your house big no there's two
guys he's coming inside
come on dude he's coming up now
I'm sure what I'm shooting but
oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
Oh Frank there you go go ahead and eat
you just keep doing that and then we win
the whole town
then we [ __ ] get to loot everything
we win damn right so we can keep playing
like that just keep just [ __ ] getting
better and better I like that more
honestly
woody fashioned first like how did he
get you through the window cope he was
he went to the next building and he just
no no he was point blank
he was point blank right there at the
window right when I started running up
the steps he shot through the window and
got me he went to the next he just came
through the door
no he came into the door because you ran
up right afterwards I looked at the
doors on the bottom floor I didn't see
anybody come in there some say I think
he came in after you
right after you yeah he came in a crazy
and I couldn't shoot him cuz I was
jumping off the crazy I should have had
both of them I was trying to kill the
guy on Frank's that's always balloon in
I would have seen that gonna window yeah
we literally had like three things
coming after us I don't know how Craig
doesn't understand he just doesn't you
know you don't understand I understand
all all things so usually what was like
will land within the first two houses of
each other and then we'll just look
and then once for all like once we get
decent weapons we just go and just
[ __ ] handle it like if you if you get
them quick then you know they're not all
loaded Pikachu zero Mapple we're
discouraged you know is then we can just
do this for houses and then like me up
here all right let me know and do a one
years act so laden your bargaining yeah
no no go straight down cuz if you go
straight down it's faster before
yeah oh yeah we're right on top of town
how many people do you see there's one I
wish you could just cut your lines yeah
there's one dude right there line and
die oh yeah right now it's gonna be fine
it's gonna be fine that's as good right
in front of me
of course Craig got banned I didn't
abandoned I didn't know where he hasn't
landed um here we go I got a gun I don't
have anything it'll be great
a lot I don't got a pan
energy drink well because they will get
you through the windows like you learned
yeah great sound [ __ ] and I got a gun
taught me a script it's all mr. dirty
here yeah yeah when in that house
already
ooh yes that's good let's go to this
next steps here that [ __ ] yeah Russian
okay I got one clip for this topic of
these names all you did
[Music]
government
oh I gots a NES sound me it's one ever
stop the twins
yes I see you I see I see how you came
around me I thought you're with that all
I gots to hang on
is there anything in this house I got a
get [ __ ] dirty car right here check this
one out
anything they loaded it they were hot
house they're not anything
it's [ __ ] crowbar I guess it's like
that shotgun choke right there's a red
dot over here I think you find it are we
gonna want to meet up with them yeah
let's do it together
there's two guys going the out of the
house
can you get him [ __ ] [ __ ] I hit one
he's [ __ ] hurt goddamnit
I'm just which ones right now coming
around to you I mean I was too [ __ ]
good I'm gonna spoon thanks thanks for
the help there coke I [ __ ] hit the
[ __ ] dude you're [ __ ] standing out
in the street like he's standing out in
a [ __ ] Street [ __ ] just know how
alright he's over here he's on Craig's
body yeah he ain't gonna get [ __ ] so
just take him out
I don't have anything but I'm going
around alright yep father he's over here
this small
yep you see him three no I do not see
where this one
there's another buddy got me down you
got me let me shoot along this wall so
money to get out oh Jesus nice nice kill
you see this guy
yeah Jarrett
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]